fire
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
oh [__] dude hey guys um thank you for
all the compliments on my pumpkin
sweater you haven't sent them in yet but
um I actually like the orange today the
orange and the blue you look like uh
like a big Denver Bronco fan I look like
a big Denver Broncos that's the original
orange and if I'm at if I'm in Denver
and I'm in in the stadium and the
Broncos are playing I'm cheering for the
Broncos that's how I am I'm a fair
weather guy well I mean we suck right
now but we do have champagne I lost some
money to you lost some money to you this
weekend and now what I what I'm
impressed by is now we used to like wait
and have to harass each other and the
juice was running I'm gonna have to
squeeze your nuts a little bit in advice
to get the money now you just send it
yeah as soon as you told ya cash out
yeah literally well because uh if
otherwise the bets aren't worth yeah no
otherwise what do we do but also
um what did I tell you though yeah yeah
right well I hate the basket in this
Glory yeah but also it's unfair too
because I can see why people are like
zero guns as Badass blah blah blah it's
by far Jon Jones easiest match of all
time
you said because I'm not like a legit
maybe three stripe white belt on the
ground and then his his wrestling very
amateur so he's not doing a thing
against the guys seven years old yeah
were you do you know that did you hear
what he said where he benches 500 to 5
20 on the bench who does Tom Jones and
he deadless 640. like I know I don't
know if I believe the badge the dead
level bench is crazy crazy because they
showed him during the countdown doing
315 he got two at like the struggle City
yeah
maybe he was he literally said it
because my nephew sent it to me I
believe him then yeah I don't know why
John would lie about that maybe maybe
he's getting big Donuts he's a law for
that he's a lot it's a lot it's a lot
that's a lot it's hard to believe but if
anyone's gonna do it's the greatest of
all time but he made it look so easy so
easy man in the next yes but this is
this is what I was telling chin on Shop
shows like
not a ton of answers
not a ton of questions have been
answered the verdict's still out and
what he looks like at heavyweight
we saw nothing you're gonna see his
cardio is striking his footwork when he
gets hit we there's still a ton of
questions be answered we'll get more
questions answered when you fight Stipe
CB's not gonna be as easy to demolish
like that but right it's gonna be a
tough fight for her well Steve Perry was
D1 wrestler so it'll be you know it'll
be a thing just give me a tougher task
but not betting against John ever again
no the only guy I'm actually curious to
see him fight eventually is that giant
Russian guy who keeps sleeping everybody
who is that guy Sergey pavlovich he's
just Pavlich fighting Curtis blades so
the winner will probably get the next
option that'd be a
hash blades possibly if
by the restaurant which I think he does
if Curtis Curtis could be a handful for
John yes with his wrestling pedigree and
he hits like a Mack truck he's getting
more comfortable with striking cardio is
good ground pounds good yeah that's a
real fight John's got his hands full
yeah yeah I think I think the next I
think the get the the dark horse that
can kind of Dethrone John would be Tom
aspinel he's 100 Health with his knee
his box is ridiculous his footwork he's
quick good cardio black belt on the
ground good wrestling he's a handful
yeah but with his leg injury he still
weighs out but all of them are you know
with that weight class you know they're
all dangerous but then there's someone
we're not talking about which I I meant
to bring up when we were talking about
it Jen there's someone we're not talking
about
you know who hold on
hold on can you guess who I'm thinking
of
um hold on
um you fight in the UFC no not in any
longer well you're talking about Francis
and Gano no okay but that was I like
where your heads out there because I'm
not no no no no I do think that could
happen I think John takes him down and
does the same exactly that's exactly
correct and that's that is what's
another easy night that's right now it's
no knock on these guys just where
they're at no that's stylistically just
where they're at ready for this um hold
on hold on I'm gonna get excited Brock
Lesnar
oh
just let it marinate for a second
think about for just a second
John has been talking about Brock for
how long he brought he's brought up in
the pre-fight interviews coming in he
brought up my post fight so it's his
dream fight Brock Lesnar's not resigning
his WWE contract you think word on the
scene how old is Brock please 40. uh 79.
um but Brock says too uh when he's doing
WWE right now and he's saying goodbye to
the the wrestlers he's 45 years old
tough one tough one for Brock because uh
Brock also has to deal with now he's not
hearing a peep out of John for wrestling
wise well his double legs world class
yep strength wise though Rocky freaky no
Rocky freaky freaky now now also but but
but but I don't know how rocky Rocky's
got to get John to not take his back
rocky rocky could easily I didn't say
Brock's gonna win he gets his he gets he
gets boxed up he gets boxed somebody
tries to stand up so he's got it he's
got a
close distance and which is what he does
yeah he always does that now now can his
cardio take Big John the the octopus
that John is when John gets behind him
oh no not a good matchup for Brock I'm
not saying that it's a huge payday it's
a job and he's been wanting now if
you're John's management team or you UFC
this is no knock on that Russian or or
uh Curtis blades or Tom aspinal but if
you're his team in the UFC
just asking for a friend who likes
orange just ask them for a friend
to make the most money possible after
John fights steep eh I'm just I'm asking
foreign and you get Brock at that fight
and he comes into the octagon and says
when we're fighting December I want you
young man now what now what's not what
sells more pay-per-views
John Brock John Curtis Blaze John
aspenoff John Brock breaks all the
records John Brock is bigger than John
Francis correct and you have Ronda
Rousey and you have Conor McGregor tag
team they're they're available see he
made a joke I'm living the real world
dude you made it weird now yeah because
this could happen you think it could
really happen yes
not some far-fetched idea but you got
you got a lot of problems with that can
can Brock be exempt from the USA
that's a big question they get a
four-month uh uh exemption stipulation
or whatever they have in the contracts
they could do that for broadcasting and
you need to hey hey they've always done
that for brocky okay you think he ever
bought natural I mean I don't know what
you're talking about Sir me neither I
have never seen a needle go into
anybody's butt me neither yeah
um the only thing he's guilty of is a
flat top right yeah flat top
um I I like that could happen I like
what you're happy because think about
this the video FC I'm trying to put
things in perspective here so you let
Francis go like yeah we'll be fine it's
like well you who's he gonna fight I'm
like oh there's a big old white fish out
there in Minnesota that can reel in
right which would be bigger than France
so you'll see like yeah go ahead and
walk yeah do your thing yeah he'll fight
zero gone fight Stipe and then he's
gonna fight Brock and then John said I
have at least two fights left I'm gonna
do two John did yeah so it's not like
he's saying I'm gonna do the next I'm
gonna do the rain champ for next five
years
he's not that interested in fighting
forever he's not that interested in
fighting those up and comers the Curtis
blades the Russians I don't think or the
Tom aspenos I don't he's like kind of
kill I'm good on that yeah I'm going for
legacy fights I'm gonna fight the goat
steep a who some referred to as a goat
I'll fight sir gong he's the current
champ he's athletic you guys think I'm
scared of him I'm gonna mop the floor
with him beat the [__] of this last
fight Brock Lesnar I ride off in the
sunset Jesus yeah I think that would be
the smartest idea rather than go with a
guy who's a real Christmas that's a
threat that's a nightmare Curtis blades
but he's such a competitor I wonder if
he wants to see how he does you know I
don't think so I think he's good he
should be very smart and he's calculated
interesting I think what happened with
Sarah Ghana is that he just hesitated
because it's the Big Show he just
[__] well I don't think he has
anything to do with it got caught
sitting down I don't think he just he
doesn't he doesn't doesn't know what to
do no yeah what was that thing he did is
that just a standard Guillotine it's a
standard Guillotine yeah didn't grab the
arm dude nothing that's what I mean he
just was kind of I think he froze up I
just don't think he's at a level he
might not even know what he what he was
what John was doing before was too late
but I was I was amazed that he didn't
John took him down and went to mount
that's what I mean like you could have
like there's a there's pretty standard
ways to there's some stuff he can do
yeah
but there wasn't any of that it's just
but think about you have you ever seen
him grapple
no Sarah Francis took him down a bunch
yeah he caught homeboy in a heel hook
yeah but it's not like you know no it's
just nightmare now now Sarah gone
story's not over he's gonna go on to
beat damn near everybody else
you know if if I were if I had been his
coach if I if Cyril gone were to fight
John again which is always possible who
knows
um
but but you don't be someone that
dominance the only thing you can do is
just go straight at John swinging like
just just try to get in the phone booth
with him and Slug It Out that's that's
probably the best thing he could do
Johnson's gonna take you down you gotta
you gotta bait him in and try to catch
him coming in yeah you can't go forward
good luck with that I know no it's a
nightmare good luck stylistically match
up why it's just nightmare for still
gone all good baby boy I'd love to see
him fight Curtis Blaze because I don't
think Curtis blades is hearing much from
his wrestling
you know but that thing while we don't
know where John's at we don't know we
learn nothing we learned that Sarah gone
cannot grapple Chuck what'd you learn
about John
and he looked a little rusty with a
stand-up in the first two minutes right
and he even alluded to it in the post
flight press conference it was a little
rusty didn't you feel that sir agama's a
little off balance and his and he was
seemed very kind of no I think you're
just so worried about the takedown and
he always moves like that Cyril did
Cyril but for John it was like we didn't
learn anything yeah literally put on a
little bit of weight we learned that the
internet's body shaming him and he's
like I do need to tighten up the
internet the greatest of all time body
shame Jon Jones and him going yeah I'll
probably tighten up for the next fight
you're like oh but dude yeah you get on
that lizard even even I even I was like
it's got a little bit of a belly little
tummy I seemed to be maybe because I'm
just used to it but like Fedor Kane
wasn't shredded like you got those guys
that has nothing to do with his fighting
well so nothing so you know doing
busting with the boys with our boy Will
Compton and Taylor Who's they're [__]
great guys to my favorite and then um
my show in Nashville uh this the
defensive tackle for the Minnesota
Vikings I think uh Russell Phillips
[__] the giant the one thing about
athletes that you see is they're they're
very rarely shredded they're very
they're they're usually like it's just a
different kind of muscles different kind
of body I don't know what it's from it's
just it depends like there's some like
like uh Aaron Donald who's a d tackles
that's right there's some fruits out
there but in general they're gonna be
mesomorph you know who's [__]
ridiculously shredded and maybe he did
it for the movie
play it Jake gyllenhoe play it out no
this is a this is an awesome Pro
defensive end I know but you see Jake
Gyllenhaal yes I did yes I did very
happy with his body very happy even
Danny goes you saw that with the
intestine did you see Magic Mike 25 or
whatever that was I missed that one
right you watch that one because I'm not
gay I had to watch that with my girl and
I'm very girl made you watch it yeah but
see I'd watch it I have nothing against
it when you watch the way Channing Tatum
dances you'll get depressed you'll go oh
I'm a piece of [__] he's so beautiful
yeah but um but uh Michael Strahan
and you go oh your your body is so
ridiculous it's so rich do you think you
had a bad body I never knew that I never
saw Michael Strahan look at that
[__] look at that mother Michael
Strahan's a monster monster Monster
did such an amazing job like it played
this male stripper I was like get the
[__] out of here
but for the most part
there's another is this another Brian
count goes gay I'm a little bit I mean
I'm just if you're not a little gay for
that then there's something going on
dude you would have had such a fun time
on the companion because you know me and
will were doing like the locker room
talk and was like you know we have a guy
in the locker room we always hey would
you have a gun to your head or suck a
dick you know Rampage ain't playing that
my favorite my favorite
I'd rather die he's like okay he's like
I've been down this road guys played
that hard ball with me he goes gun to
your kid's head or you suck a dick
I love will good questions because you
know Will's been down that road a
thousand times that's how we talk not
not rampant Rampage whatever answering
if we and then finally we got him then
you see me and Will it's like yeah
it's immature yeah immature speaking of
bodies that don't look like they've been
doing
you know speaking of regular bodies
an outstanding athletes
how do you feel about Bo nickel
oh his body well first of all well
swelsters don't look like that unless
you're like your Joel Romero
fairly muscular uh but they're not like
super like cut and shredded like yeah he
just looks he just looks so modest it
modestly built modestly built and
ridiculous as an athlete him and Bill
Burr have the same body yeah it's just
but he's just that body's just built off
straight up technique technique good
luck the way he put those don't like
having a six-pack and beating him [__]
but again get some questions for Bo
nickel right it's like where does he go
from here you know so here's my thing
about Bo nickel if you go to the ground
with them you're going to have some
you're gonna have some big problems
you're going to the ground you're going
with it you don't have a just you don't
have a choice
um but we have not
seen him with a guy that can see this is
the problem strike this is the problem
with sports yeah we have seen the guys
that can strike he's coming again now
have we seen him with a [__] Izzy no
dude uh no he is Brian this is my
problem with all boxes he's gonna see
MMA Community you know that everyone's
like man I'd love to see him in there
with he's only 20. name a [__]
world-class kickboxer like he has three
fights same thing happens with Jake Paul
let's see him in their Canelo he's five
[__] five what I thought of though I
thought of um Ben askren and Ben askren
was just different amazing getting you
in a position and and [__] you up by
different wrestling different when you
got when you saw Ben you saw him
compromise with a bad hip in the UFC yes
that's very true Beau nickel is a in his
prime B could actually strike Ben didn't
work on striking never ever he didn't
agree with it well so Beau does it all
and bow striking is good because if you
watch his Contender Chase fights he's
[__] he's not out yeah these [__]
dudes up yeah yeah that's the question
is how how much progress does he make
with a striking probably a lot because
he's a great athlete and has been
growing up watching people nobody you
need to watch him in the contenders his
strike he should not he should not look
this good with three fights in it's
insane he's ridiculous and balls at all
all the boys ATT are like oh dude he he
does everything he's also in that he's
also in that camp ATT that gym is no
joke he's got all kinds of well but he's
not trading on his gym he's not his
Gym's in uh Mike Brown was cornrow
Pennsylvania yeah because he has an ATD
in uh uh was it College Park where he's
at or State Park the State College Park
yeah some [__] yeah yeah I was wondering
my question was is he going to be a Ben
Astron is he going to be able to get how
far is he getting that's a bad guy
that's a bad comparison it is yeah it's
bad because I wanted as far as he get
with the wrestling different style
different styles of wrestling one was
compromised when he came in uh one
didn't believe in Striking didn't didn't
work on it Bose a complete mixed martial
artist just happens to be the Savage at
wrestling and his jiu-jitsu filthy as
[__] [__] crazy the way he like No
One's Gonna Give him no one's giving him
real issues till you get to the top ten
yeah and even then then he's gonna the
guys who will give him issues later on
or comes out those kind of guys who've
done a lot of wrestling you know and
they're gonna have their hands full
they're gonna have well yeah they're
gonna have their hands they're gonna
take you now
take them down but it just can he keep
them down what happens when they get
back up when they him in the face when
they're in the fourth round we'll see
Beau was saying that he wrestled on the
international circuit and he was like he
was talking about the [__] guys he was
talking about yeah I told you he did on
a food truck
standards taking over the Russian song
he was what how'd you do against me I've
been competing against those people
since I was seven and how'd you do this
oh Tech Fallen dude oh yeah of course
it's stupid
he's a freak like it's not it's
different he's not only a freak he's
he's just a champion you can see his
mentality is ridiculous he's got that
mentality that's what he's there for
he's not there to participate
as Conor said I'm not here until I'm
gonna take over
but yeah he has but people just gotta
just give him time it's a marathon not a
Sprint we don't need them fighting who
do they get mixed are they gonna are
they going to bring them up slowly is
the question well there's no slow with
him but they got to keep him on that
fast track but you don't toss them A
ranked guy yet so you do the shot I
think he can beat the rank guys even
sean O'Malley's a little slow for bow
nickel no slow yeah he's gonna be put on
a fast track than what would you do give
him three years
no no I'd give him uh three fights three
fights then we're going top top 15. top
15. no I'm saying he'll be fighting top
15 by next year yeah that's fine now if
you give him top five top five next year
uh end of the year next year he'll be
top five I bet
but you know he did find a guy who's
coming off two losses right Jamie
Pickett he was gonna get taken down so
next time you give him a guy who's not
ranked but maybe has three wins wins in
a row see how and if he annihilates him
it's like all right let's give him a guy
who's on like a four fight win streak
right outside top 15 annihilates him all
right here we go will they do that yeah
guaranteed yeah yeah because he's a star
they want him think about it he only has
four fights his first fight ever with
his son UFC 285 on the main card they
know how special he is and America needs
him Americans need a badass like this
100 well he has a lot of pressure on him
yeah but he's used to pressure that guy
oh it doesn't get dummy going forward no
yeah I mean they're competitors they're
just they've been competing it's like
sehudo Cormier Joel Romero all these
Olympians these World cheers
they're used to it and wrestling is such
a [__] nightmare Sport and Bo was
saying like he competed on that high
level he's like like I was performed in
front of 3 000 people when I was like
10. yeah winning the State title yeah
it's just it's it's what he does yeah he
grew up doing it yeah yeah
God damn I did a good card though I'm So
speaking of staying in shape I don't
know if you've ever done this and I
don't know what it does but you know
there's this these this scientists
they're like we have to lift ways to be
in shape oh no what if we put on an
electric suit a suit that shocks your
muscles this is old school man it is of
course right so I put on this this whole
suit that you that they wet down and
then the electricity gets stronger and
stronger so it's like
at the end of it I was going like I
couldn't even I was like like it brings
your whole body that like and that was
at 180 whereas uh it goes up to 400
which could kill an elephant yeah and
I'm very sore as a result but I don't
think it didn't my muscles no right I've
had this around for years so what is it
then it's just like the idea but also
gets like uh like when I tore my
hamstring they gave me one of those
devices because it get because they also
shut down won't work yeah so fire
stimulates the muscle fresh blood goes
through there it's not
but also hey just get a weight room
right I was in the weight room yeah but
not enough I did a 20 minute
workout with it and that's dude yeah
yeah but just do like very sore in the
ass and body though I would say this
sure so maybe it's uh maybe it's just
from like that fatigue in your muscles
tearing the muscle down getting stronger
where for you see what happens
he literally like you cannot it's so
interesting to be shocked like that
because your whole body just goes that's
old technology though yeah like people
you do it for abs I remember kids in
college would wait for the ABS and just
shock the ABS yeah that's stupid yeah
yeah I don't think it makes your abs no
it does nothing no just fatigue makes
you really sore and fatigued right
because you're constantly like oh
instead of sitting there eating [__]
peanut butter if you kept doing this all
the time like that you would be sore
your whole body but I'm not like
shredded dude that was yeah that was
really a weird
this one yeah that was a good time yeah
and that was a really good time well how
about me I'm like I can move there
anyway
I get that because I was in nature I
should live in Naples I could definitely
live in Naples
so cool love it
this one's someone says that sold
outside like steep fate
that's so funny
that's great
congrats on your first ever sold out
show people are silly [__] I love it
it's funny though
yeah I did I did I was in Bridge Tim
Segura standing outside what Tom's a
girl that's a Tim Segura oh all right
there to the left with a shaved head
that's funny Thomas lost all the weight
oh yeah
yes [__]
amazing you know it is no secret that
injuries suck oh my god dude you ever
been in a car accident you're like what
am I gonna do I don't wanna you gotta
Lords are so expensive is there an
option I could choose look it's not a
confusing it's not a hard process if you
have Morgan and Morgan they actually
make it easy okay you can you can start
a claim from your couch in six on my
phone yes okay and if you don't want uh
to call that's okay you can text back
and forth from your lord wait hold on
can you tell me this is free it's all
free and I only pay if I win my case yes
wow Morgan and Morgan America's largest
injury Law Firm has 900 lawyers 900
offices 24 7 customer service staff and
they recovered over 15 billion buckaroos
for their clients all you have to do is
dial pound law or go to forthepeople.com
fighter that's Dow pound law or
forthepeople.com fighter that's Dow
pound law or forthepeople.com fighter
this is a paid advertisement now let's
get back to the program
when I was in Tahiti uh some of the
there they're a robust powerful people
the women as well I had a massage from a
number of tahitians but you did Playboy
and much stronger than I am
well that's why in uh Thailand like the
ladyboys kids because they're thin
already like the guys have small
shoulders you get dude structure to be
you know someone just died upstairs yeah
yeah that's right
um well guys are you headed this are you
on the road this weekend
I'm going to New York City Hall Sony all
I got uh I feel like moving to New York
in a while well you went to New York to
promote your special but as far as shows
goes I haven't been a long time either
me neither because Gotham City is not a
headliner Club anymore and then Caroline
shut down shut down yeah Caroline shut
down oh wow you just find out I did I
was at institution yeah Caroline shut
down yeah so that's why I'm doing Sony
Hall yeah get your tickets
briancount.com and then I got Wes Nyack
I'm right back to New York West Nyack
but that's not really about Manhattan
I'm talking like right real New York so
there's Gotham City and then there you
know
there's some the town hall one's big
like there's not a ton of places to
perform there anymore unless you're just
a huge name
Tony Hall be fun for you though I'm in
Oklahoma city breaks down Comedy Club
this Thursday Friday Saturday great Club
one of my favorite clubs best Boys best
security ever that guy's great yeah he's
my favorite him and his wife are my
favorite I won't be going on Oklahoma
City Bombing tour like I did last time
that ruined my day it's so sad yeah
because I have cheers of the kids that
were killed they're like little chairs
it ruined my day as well I will never go
to it again as well yeah it's such a
bummer man such a bummer
so don't do that in Oklahoma City but
they have good barbecue and food out
there so I'm looking forward to that and
I'm in Tacoma Washington again not a lot
of things do in Seattle now there's no
club in Seattle now so you got to do so
much weird right nothing to do with
Tacoma March 23rd to 25th yeah Seattle
and Chicago Chicago now has a Zanies
well Chicago has zany's Laugh Factory
um and then there's another the
Schomburg which is outside the city and
then the theaters are great at the big
theater the Italian Hall yeah they have
some great big boys yeah Chicago theater
is great I mean yeah Chicago Theater but
Chicago as far as like uh like uh they
have Schaumburg yeah because they have
so many theaters they don't need a club
I guess you know yeah it's dangerous
small Laugh Factory is a good club
though holds a lot too I've never been
yeah big room but they don't do
headliner weekends not really yeah yeah
the only reason I was able to do I think
30. I saw a Chris Rock special do you
see it I didn't see it it's a Saturday
night I like it man it got bad reviews
by certain people and I'm like what's
bad Hollywood Reporter uh [__] I'm
like but think about it yeah holiday
report is leans which way right
no left yeah I'm like you said right
this is really good you just said right
no they they lean left yeah and they
were mad again
the funniest thing he goes uh he was
like I went to Lululemon and they had we
don't discriminate against you know we
we hate we stand against racism and hate
and all that and he's like I know but
you charge a hundred dollars for the
yoga pants so you do discriminate
against the poor I'd rather have twenty
dollar I'd rather buy twenty dollar
racist yoga pants it was so [__] true
it's like you guys act so holier than
now but you charge that much money get
the [__] out of here and I was thinking
I was like I wonder how Will Smith feels
now it's like will you had your time you
embarrassed Chris oh bro now oh my God
guys I did see that cut out so I was
like all right will you had your time
right you had your your day and you
embarrassed Chris and now he's taking
one over a year because the the goal the
Oscars are this weekend or this weekend
yeah Sunday it's like so you had your
time and Chris didn't say much took it
on the chin literally took on the chin
but now you [__] with a comic so now
it's his turn Revenge
he's been working in the [__] kitchen
getting this sauce ready dude I mean he
ended his whole show that way the whole
place like I was like how many times
they call him a [__] oh dude I was like
this
and the last gosh am I spoiling it if I
say what the last line is no I don't
think so I didn't hear it it's all over
social media the last line was it was
heavy man yeah it was [__] I I really
think he's Will Smith is going to have a
hard time for a while walking away from
that this has been oh yeah right I mean
Legend I mean
because historic moment so it's never
happened it was so inappropriate and you
got to pay the price and then you gotta
eat now now Will Smith you know he
didn't get verbally you know physically
slapped but verbally he's almost worse
now than just two you're [__] with
Chris Rock one the best ever do it
dealt with yeah
it's really interesting man it's like
nobody you know but that's how this goes
that's how this goes yeah you don't get
away with that yeah
and uh and if you thought he forgot or
you thought he was no but he but he he
couldn't do a special not address all
this yeah he did he waited till minute
61.
it says the first ever live event yeah
my Netflix yeah that's pretty cool yeah
pretty cool [__] and then it gets
uploaded to it
yeah it'd be interested to see how many
people watch that
I think a lot I think a lot of people
tons tons tons I would assume just as
streaming was massive for Netflix first
time ever live on Netflix I don't think
he ever talks to Wells Will Smith again
or maybe maybe he does I don't know I
bet you they do over time I think they
should I think there's always you know
it is what it is forgiveness is
important yeah you don't hold that
resentment I'm sure it was good I wonder
if I bet will expected this he's like
yeah that's what I get I knew this was
coming take your medicine yeah oh
it's good though huh yeah
yeah oh we talked about it on uh I think
Wednesdays with Brett Forte but that uh
Alex Murdoch trial came to a conclusion
he got tried you hear what the judge
said oh he said well maybe it wasn't you
maybe the monster inside of you did it
and then the just finished it off and
goes he goes your discipline clearly
just give me the sentence they give you
but also every night when you put your
head down on that pillow and close your
eyes you're gonna see that boy who I'm
sure you loved that one time looking
back at you because you murdered him and
his mom he's like that's your sentence
God it's like cool and then now shows
every night you know I'm sure you will
it's going to continue that way and now
I'm gonna give you one life sentence for
killing your son another life sentence
for killing your wife have a good day
now the sun unfortunately has that red
hair and looks a lot like Dad but uh are
you talking about Busters he's having a
hard time that's got to be tough for
that kid well he has some charges head
his way too for killing that young gay
man oh so he's yeah he was the kid yeah
well both of them have issues well they
both kill people yeah the whole family
we don't know but we don't know that he
does but allegedly the the thing's never
been he he was at the scene the last
person talked to that young man who died
is him he had a sexual relation with him
he's [__] oh sorry is he a gay man
yeah and they're singing that's why he
killed him because he was going to talk
about it because he's gonna put shame on
the family name he's a bad person too
well I mean the whole family Jesus
Christ and that and the other brother
was drunk and killed the girl yes and
then also hid his girlfriend like
terrible person yeah these are not no
the whole thing dad dad is uh they
killed the nanny pushed down the stairs
she basically raised the sun yeah what
yeah oh you didn't hear about this no
check this out
push the nanny down because he had a
drug problem and she was the nanny so
she would [__] she found his drugs it's
like hey I don't be in the middle of
this brought it to the the wife and the
son and they're like you gotta do you
gotta handle this because he hid the all
his like or uh uh Oxycontin pills under
his son's bed and she found him cleaning
the [__] room so she brought it to
their attention and then she was gonna
like say something and they think the
why for the son killed her pushed her
bashed her head and hit her on the
stairs so then they said she tripped
over the dog which they nobody believes
so then tripped over so then they have
their hands like with the cops so they
don't do investigation to any of it
they'll do autopsy on the body nothing
and then he goes oh don't worry I'm
gonna take care of the family and the
guy I think it was like seven million
dollars
because his name wasn't on the property
it's some weird Insurance gappy figured
out so that he got seven million dollars
he's like I'm gonna give to the family
the family never received a dime so he's
[__] the the whole thing they're gonna
be going through a long list of
well what an awful human being man
he's just a terrible person
you know [__] him
terrible right the whole family just
just a total sociopath to put the whole
family sucked yeah the whole family
might have that issue they just might be
one thing to be ugly but mean too
right well that's right that's some very
red hair what'd I tell you about
redheads I think that you might be day
one since you met me what I said never
trust around a bit you know never trust
a red it ain't right look at him it
ain't right look at that guy oh look at
his eyes
yeah he seems like a real sweetheart
they said you have anything to say I
didn't kill my son or wife like come on
dude give it up bro just tell us
he's a lot chubbier back then huh
oh man was he ever he's lost a lot of
weight yeah well that's because of the
drugs
he was doing a lot of drugs yeah
you mean Murdoch was yeah the father
what was his drug of choice uh
painkillers like you spending or
something like crazy amount of money on
it okay then
okay then
yeah they have that hair
yeah they're trying him to detox he's
like shaking on the couch and [__] yeah
well this is when the roosters come home
to roost
yeah the chickens come home I don't know
it's time to pay the piper time to pay
the piper everyone it's interesting
right
well you use two different guns
the thing that [__] him is his son
because they have a dog kennel where the
sun was shot his son went live on
Instagram and Alex when they brought him
in for question he was I was never there
can't prove it was not there like okay
cool say less they get a son's phone
they bring up his old Instagram videos
at the exact time five minutes after
he's murdered you hear his dad on the
video come on yeah
yes [__] dumbass yeah they always say
that somebody goes Okay I lied I was
there but I ran back in the house like
okay dumbass they say that sociopaths
one of the the big the I guess the most
common
um reaction is when they're caught
surprise when when they can't believe
they got caught they can't believe they
actually got caught that it happened to
them they were like wait I'm actually
going yeah yeah they're not mad that
they killed somebody they're mad that
they actually got caught part of being
especially about is thinking that you
are God's favor that you're so special
that you can do anything and you never
get caught so you can pull off huge
financial schemes you can kill you you
can kill your wife and your son you can
just it's all sloppy because I'll never
catch you because you're smarter than
everybody else you're better how could
anybody be like and the other thing is
from narcissists and sociopaths the
people that I have known in my life that
are real narcissists yeah they it's
always someone else's fault they can be
standing on an island ability nothing
[Music]
we've had those people around us yeah
and you're like okay yeah yeah no
accountability it's just everybody
else's fault everybody else's fault
you're at your in your life because of
everybody else
and you're that old that tracks okay
that makes sense
it's it's uh it's it's never a good
policy it doesn't work out no never does
what do you got Chad
taking a little scan here
um oh so this is a little bit older but
so this is Wendy Williams talking about
her weight loss she had some health
issues earlier yeah just before you go
into that you know about this drug
ozampic and it's really everybody's
taking that yeah ozempic yeah it's a
it's a diabetes drug But like everyone
it doesn't seem to have any real um side
effects diarrhea people are taking it
gives you diarrhea it does yeah people
it just like it kills your appetite you
take a shot a week and I know a guy
who's taking it now injections
injections that's a small like insulin
needle I know a ton of people that take
it I've seen it yeah you you do yeah you
take one shot once a week the
Kardashians took it right like yeah
they've done some other things but yeah
they're the ones who made it famous but
then also it doesn't last forever you
can't just do it for the rest of your
life it has a shelf life oh really yeah
like after like I forget what it is like
three months four months it your body
reacts to it yeah everything is up it to
a certain amount and then it could be
here work hard
diet yeah yeah yeah what made you think
of that be
I don't know because of Wendy Williams
losing all that weight oh yeah yeah I
might do it
yeah so I saw
this is the first time she's actually
been in public since the weight loss
but she looks like this oh not body
shaming but you know she's a really tall
girl too or she's tall and thick but she
feels like she's healthy now at 1 38.
huh yeah that's uh can I see well her
legs are so fit it's very strange
strange look yeah yeah the whole thing
wow that is a weird look she looks um
there's been some work there yeah yeah I
don't know I don't know I thought she
looks better when she's a little thicker
yeah yeah same definitely well but I
mean if she's if she's actually
healthier now then that's great but I
don't know it doesn't seem healthy like
there's a fine line there right was she
the one who's husband ended up cheating
on her and something like that yeah
she doesn't look tall she's a character
very very unsteady on her on her legs
yes I think that guy must be super tall
because I'm pretty sure she's tall yeah
she's not short person she's not that
guy's a giant yeah
um
when she was younger she was a dime
piece right let me see her when she was
let me see those other pictures go to
that juice Bigelow said that's a huge
[__]
did
I liked her when she was born right here
that looks healthy yeah he looks healthy
more weight on her
yeah
I'm right here to stuff the giant
bangers
where did those go away what's that yeah
I'm talking about those huge fun bags
the bangers
that's just Giants I love those awesome
blossoms in the front or no some big Big
M yeah well anyway that's a rough
sometimes plastic surgery and stuff can
be I don't think that's well she said
plastered I bet her weight loss who
knows what that's going on though but it
doesn't seem like she seems healthy like
there yeah she doesn't look as healthy
now even though she feels healthier so
that's why I brought it how old is she
she's an older woman
50s right her and Charlemagne started
together
I think Charlotte needs to work with her
on radio she's got lymphedema 58. yeah
okay she's pretty for 58.
yeah yeah she's pretty
yeah because she she was a DJ you know
that she's like a a shock joke that's
how she got famous and so was
Charlemagne South Carolina yep
she's pretty there all right and uh this
is also a little bit older
um but so that that guy Brian how do you
pronounce his name coburger
so there's a there's a legislator a
lawmaker that wants to because I guess
in that area in Idaho there's a chance
that they can't find Lethal Injections
like the chemicals they need they can't
they're not sure they can do that so you
can't ship it through also gives a [__]
just shoot them yeah so this lawmaker is
like asking for legislation to bring in
a firing squad if they here's a trivia
question when was the last time in
France when was the last time you used
the guillotine when was the last time a
criminal had their head cut off 81. no
Maria Antonella way before about I don't
know 70s no 90s so you you are so it's
actually 1981 was when they made it
illegal 1977 was the last time they
chopped someone's head off
like that's kind of cool you should chop
this kid's head off but the only reason
I knew they were considering yeah I know
it's super painless the only reason I
knew they're considered a firing squad
is because theopostale said light them
up
and they think he did murders uh in
Washington the same similar and he
studied something yeah he studied
technology to make sure he was a good
like [__] murderer yeah light him up
he's a [__] bazooka did they had
video of someone that looked like him at
the um Memorial yeah
real psychopath
yeah just like to see what he had done
they were such beautiful young kids
terrible
and he does just reality he does look
like a freaking killer yeah you gotta
kill him there's no there's no reason to
put him in prison when do you think
you're gonna get caught chin do I look
like a killer a little bit a little bit
really if I found out you were killing
people with those guccis [__] told
you I always said we didn't know
anything about the private
yeah I was like what do you do this
weekend uh you know just stuff huh oh
it's stuck I'm not busy my family camera
brought noodles my stuff do you mean
quartering a human being draining him of
his blood in your bathtub and putting it
in here my mom can't remember
all weekend now and what did you eat
with those noodles right a human liver
cool I do love liver I know yeah I bet
you do man lover
uh real quick Georgie are these a little
too old are we good with these
um I asked what would happen with him in
jail probably too old right and and uh
this prison guard was like uh he'll just
be considered a weirdo he'll be fine who
uh yeah he didn't kill any kids but he's
also want to be in general let's be the
guy he'll just be weird people have died
you know how in prison like even when we
had homeboy on we were talking about
prison we're like oh any butt stuff you
ever thought about I was talking with
somebody who's been in the princess but
like hey man all the gay stuff you got
to stop that's a Hollywood agenda that's
these directors making prison movies
because they have this weird gay fantasy
prison ain't like that dude he's like
it's really not made they're for sure
there's some gay guys in there and
there's the [__] stuff but in general
you don't have to worry about getting
[__] all the time he's like that's
what Hollywood decided to make you guys
think yeah he's like because these
directors like you know whoever this
director is they have this idea like man
oh and they're gonna [__] each other
he's like it's not like that in any
facet no he's like does guys get raped
and stuff does it happen yeah is it a
real occur in prom all the time is the
first thing you know that's because you
go in you're thinking that because of
Hollywood my buddy said that there are a
lot of guys that give it away like there
are gay men in prison yes you don't have
to yeah there's this whole thing but
he's saying it's not like this big [__]
fest when you walk in he's like that's
Hollywood make you think like oh prison
guys don't see girls you're gonna [__]
well think about it like he's like it's
not like how long I'm in prison I'm not
gonna find you more attractive it's not
like yeah hold him down
I'm easy I mean at least but this guy's
a good point right he's like no that's
the Hollywood agenda dude yeah he's like
prison's not like that not everyone's
busting nuts and butts
alrighty uh so we talked about um
nothing nothing just gonna nothing you
sure remember that girl that killed the
Husky thinking it was a wolf goddamn she
killed more no this is a different
Hunter I was like this [__] is just a
serial killer at this point
so this is in Danbury Connecticut I
think this is where Glover takes service
from as well so this Hunter he's like in
his 60s well that's where Glover trains
he's from trains yeah yeah trains
so this Hunter killed two different dogs
the the dogs got out of their gate
because I think the owner said that a
bear might have cracked it open so they
left yeah and then the guy thought they
were coyotes so he killed him and skin
them and these are the dogs right here
well well that's that so my German
Shepherd looks a lot like a coyote yeah
I'm saying this is probably closer to
the yeah yeah but I would I would know
that's a [__] dog me too come on dude
it's a real problem
like that's a people also see what they
want to see right so like there was a
big ass cougar there's a coyote in my
yard big ass coyote never once I was
like that's a dog because I'm not
trained to think that way out there in
the sticks where you got to worry about
all that [__] like connect two million
sticks though it's good in your backyard
I've spent certain parts of Connecticut
are in the sticks man you know yeah
yeah you know up near yeah not for your
Manhattan you're skinning a [__]
Dalmatian you got problems yeah and you
gotta just look at that dog no that's a
dog how you doing if the dog comes over
to you you know yeah and also they're
mannerisms if the dog's wagging it you
know you're hunting and you're just so
you're itching to shoot anything you
know you know I gotta admit Brian I
think some of those Hunters probably do
that it might have been dark you see it
now [__] up that is to shoot
somebody's dog and his skin and skin
them alive because you could see them in
like next to your face after they're
dead right like you could tell it's a
dog he said the dog's heads were removed
remain missing I'm sorry but this all
gets a little like I'm gonna chop his
head off and I'm gonna skin him as well
so I can stuff the head might be a guy
who gets off on killing dog he said he's
embarrassed by this and all that stuff
and he's probably gonna get charged he's
like I'll take the heads off my mantle
it's embarrassing
yeah yeah someone's like Daddy what do
you have two German Shepherds heads on
your fireplace well there was this
[__] idiot in in uh Australia this
guide and they're up in the Northern
Territory on the river and these it's a
canoeing that's the thing right yeah now
um obviously so what do you not do in
the rivers of Northern Australia what do
you not do I don't even go in pools in
Australia thank you yeah no water but if
the river is murk if it's brown sediment
then it's a river mangroves what do you
know yeah yeah and see something over
there it's not a log it's
it's a
crocodile right well it's not friendly
yeah so dum dum has 13 people
and and he uh they you know make camp
and stuff like that and uh
he just figured he saw some like uh
muscle freshwater mussels that looked
like they've been eating and there was
some maybe somebody built a fire and he
had seen Aborigines the like day before
who maybe were washing in some part of
the bank yeah so he goes so he goes he
goes yeah he goes it's now get this it's
9 00 P.M
and dum-dum says Let's go swim in the
water hole it's fine to swim over here
we can do that because and everyone's
like yeah they and they all went yay and
they jumped in the water
yeah
and uh
well the the river's over there I don't
know if you know crocodile swim and as
they're all frolicking in the water they
come back out they come well luckily
they just come back out of the water and
one of the women is missing she's just
gone they were playing they're all like
and she just disappeared because what
they do is you don't scream they go and
we'll see you later junk like that and
then how about this they're like you
know come to think of it I did feel
something big brush my leg and another
person goes I did hear her go ah like
that but I thought she was joking and
then of course they then 15 foot
crocodile
still had her in the mouth in four in
the morning as the sun was coming up
like it's just right yeah yeah just
waiting for her to rot yeah waiting for
it Jesus Christ and and this dumb this
phone dumb guy well he got they they
brought him up on criminal charges
because he's rightfully so they're all
sitting there and this dumb guide was
like well I figured that Aborigines had
been there and I figured it was safe if
they were swimming so you didn't know
you [__] idiot as you were that there
was a problem let's take extreme
ownership here right yeah so if I'm on
that hunt or whatever the [__] that is
if I'm on that weird gate I'm never
getting in that water nine at night
Amazon nine at night and then you let's
get in the water I go one question yeah
are you telling me you know for a fact
there's no saltwater crocs there if you
go there could be we're not going
there's never I don't hate how stupid
his excuse was well I figured they were
they were fresh water and so they don't
attack humans but you saw all the giant
crocodiles on the bank his punishment
should be swimming in that water I mean
they should go all right dude you're
gonna deal with what she dealt with you
got to make it from this bank to that
bank did you see Wild crowd country did
you see that on Netflix oh dude insane
holy [__] he has to catch huge
crocodiles relocate them Giants I never
saw it I said what you told me
[Music]
um
these are their eyes I don't know if
that's a good huge croc oh my God that's
not a good crop like egg John about it
like I saw I obsessed with Crocs
I know but you know
so if I'm on YouTube and it goes and
this is why you never swim click me too
like the woman who
her can you start getting attacked by a
giant croc and she goes okay I'm gonna
jump from here my boat she's a little
heavy older I'm gonna jump my boat
do it I'm gonna yeah
and she the boat didn't have you know
when you push off a boat it doesn't
really have any yeah oh there's because
it's not on grass and she goes she as
she's stepping onto the tree Mr
Crocodile comes up and grabs her right
between the legs yeah pulls her into the
water and starts to roll her she was a
bigger woman so she starts sticking her
fingers in the thing's nostrils exactly
so
um Mr Crocodile I didn't like her go he
was like she then goes let me try to
pull myself up on the tree now she's not
she hasn't been doing a lot of Pull-Ups
so she's like I can crocodile grabs the
old leg rips It Wide Open oh [__] gives
her another death roll she's like I'm
going under oh my God she survived for
whatever reason Will Ferrell fingers
again in his nostrils not she thinks
it's the eyes but it's actually the
nostrils The Croc is like I don't like
your fingers in my [__] nostrils
somehow lets her go and she climbs up
the mud bank but she keeps falling back
down because she's grabbing she's
and she finally makes the alligator just
like holy [__] she tries to walk
collapses because her leg is completely
[__] up she doesn't search party found
her she survived oh [__] yeah she
survived you think she lost weight I was
waiting for her though didn't move oh
he's waiting for her to roll back down
yeah like a [__] Tootsie Roll she was
a feminist professor
taught feminism
and was it a male alpha male crocodile
party was full of men that's called
circle of life it's a good it's the
circle of life man at least she fought a
good fight though can you imagine I'm
gonna just step on this okay right in
the [__] right in the old puss
oh
God that uh anywhere but there and he's
like you know what let me try that big
ass thick leg of yours
yeah right in the tank
tank the front of the pool in the back
right she got teeth in her [__] oh
yeah 100 I'm gonna grab you right there
guys I'll take that
are you gonna take a big step onto a
tree nah it's what I do I am Bush and I
can come out of the water I wonder if
after that she's like I need to lose
weight oh Jesus Christ who or did she
survive because she's such a thick girl
that might have been it she's a big big
lady yeah you gotta Double Down You're
bigger just in case Crocs yeah bigger
lady Jesus Christ Jesus Christ right
yeah I had read about it before yeah I
had read about it before and she she was
like boy I think I'd rather just die she
let go of the brands because she thought
she was gonna get her leg pulled off she
goes I'd rather just drown now see that
we don't believe that right because
she's not thinking that way she didn't
have the strength
[__] hey hey here's the thing you have
no option [__] no yeah yeah it wasn't
like you were gonna power muscle up and
why because their bites are the
strongest of anything in the animal and
why because they're three thousand
pounds there's 300 pounds you can't do a
push-up and you think you're gonna pull
your wet body with this limp leg um what
do we always say Brandon you sing to the
level of your training right and when a
crocodile comes on what happens is you
freeze you don't rise to the level you
freeze up but the Crocs everything gets
pitched in sync this [__] didn't at all
no she's a big girl I ripped her [__]
off ripped her leg off she kept on
fighting might not have tasted good
all right uh before Georgie's current
event there's since you guys are talking
about crocodiles and alligators this
just happened
the last few days oh not this one
another person walking by a [__]
Florida Riverbank it is Florida good job
yeah look at this Florida and this is a
gator going through a fence there's no
sound unfortunately but this is a gator
going through a fence and look how
easily it gets through there
that's a strong animal
I've seen it fit though it didn't show
all the way but I mean I'm sure he made
it yeah he's like [__] your friends oh
my God uh yeah so this one Georgie
um so I saw a video of a six foot two
238 pound d-linemen who ran a four four
four and then posted a four three nine
what price what it's this kid here
Alabama uh defined or no uh what's his
name wait he's black Nolan Smith
oh what
well that quarterback is he white or
black I'm asking I don't know he's black
not that it makes a difference I'm not
saying there's anything that's him right
there you're surprised yeah that uh that
quarterback for Ford is a [__] freak
too really I wasn't even running full
speed did I see this yeah I'm not sure
we can play oh my God
this was the four four six two 240
pounds so he's outside back he's gonna
Rush In he ran a four three nine are you
[__] kidding could you tell he's out
fast from that yeah he's [__] rolling
I mean think about that kind of so this
is him compared to uh saquan Stefan
Diggs and Christian McCaffrey which is
nuts you're much faster is than those
two those two are oh my so fast on the
field oh my Lord
um that's nuts wonderful crazy sure and
that's all his friends all his college
buddies supporting him during the
combine and that's just because they
know how fast he is yeah like watch this
oh my god dude
yeah he's gonna get drafted high now
he's a rush in
Lord so he would be a he's a what a
defensive end but like a Von Miller type
like a hype like a middle linebacker
outside
what's the difference between a middle
linebacker an outside linebacker outside
America is kind of like outside
linebackers after cover uh the tight
ends the receivers and they gotta rush
so the quarterback So that's fast
especially this is the new standard like
the fast
was that what uh uh or Locker was and no
no uh Lawrence Taylor was he was or like
was a middle linebacker what's this Jen
all right this should be the last one
this is uh this is in Italy and I guess
two guys were vacationing with their
friends in this area and then they rent
I don't know if they rented or these are
their Ferraris but there's two different
Ferraris in this little this little turn
here right
and I will show you the video right now
so apparently this is a very sharp turn
and they were they were probably racing
there's no audio to this either but
there's a regular car just going
whatever
oh both of them oh flew and hit this
first of all that's a Pista 48 Pista
which are bad named him here which I
don't know what the hell that is
296 GTB and a f-12 Berlin did they get
really [__] F12 and 296 Jeep they had
to get uh to the hospital for sure but
I'm not sure how badly they were let me
go back 10 I'm pretty sure that's a
piece though they might be off I mean
like I've had a
f12. rewind a little bit let me pause it
keep going
I guess they could be a GTB a new one
with that
dude that's like ins just cars ruined
Ferraris right into the wall yeah
yeah and they both survived yeah they
both survived okay yeah I think so
someone even mentioned that the the
person with this house probably set up a
camera because cars did fly into the
pool or something in their backyard
before that's why they said I doubt that
I doubt it's a real problem cars flying
on your pool I think they set up a
camera for the backyard the glass
[__] door there yeah and that's a
ring because that's crazy but also make
that wall the same wall in Florida so
Gators can't [__] get through it I
know that was dude two cars that weigh
that much yeah you got air time too yeah
[__]
it's an f-12 Berlin Nita berlinita
if you fast forward here you'll see one
of them does burn up the other one
doesn't but that one's like smoking like
crazy this one here that's fine over
there
all right
what a sharp turn they just didn't see
it just kept going forward I mean they
must have been racing that happens yeah
yeah
deserves a Ferrari that's it I'm gonna
go to the bathroom and then we'll do our
dates I'm in Oklahoma now let me do it
you only get two so do you I'm Oklahoma
City this Thursday Friday Saturday hold
that big wiener Oklahoma City uh
Brickstone Comedy Club this Thursday
Friday Saturday then March 23rd through
the 25th Tacoma Washington right outside
Seattle Tacoma comedy club I'm seeing me
this weekend this Saturday Sony Hall
March 11th one night only Brian
callan.com then Levity Live I'm there
March 16 17 18 uh in West Nyack New York
come get some
love you guys